Giám đốc ờ thành phố chiming được xí lỗi sò mùi năm bị bắt hoàn.
Năm 2 ngày người hai tôi lên đăng hông tụi đi xe công rình.
Này tôi phải đi xe cà bàn như thế này đây.
Từ mùi người quái hạnh, trong thúc đình như tôi có cối,
này tôi đã chơi thành kế vô cối.
Bây bí bố tôi vì tôi đi vắc tổ, bị đại mà bánh vô qua đổi.
Bởi tôi cũng bị dừng này, bánh bánh năng này, bánh thần tôi cũng bị dừng này,
mà đổ rất bao nhiêu là bánh thật.
Tóc khi ra tôi bị chá từ dơ,
có đi bỏ 2 ngày nông cấp bị tâm.
Nhưng tôi phải tiếp tục mang thân bận biết kai xuống,
và trở đời tôi hơn năm bên trời,
bây giờ mình biết tình được tình chỉ và chỉ có mặt dùng cho đại kì hoang tư,
lúc nói tốt đồng này tôi.
Thật chơi kiểu thay lời kì hoang tốt,
hấm và đau thí cơ tổ mỗi lúc gần như thế bọc.
Tôi cũng như thế cảm hoa người.
Không một ai trong tư tà mông mù,
mình bị rơi vào có hạnh cắn phải nhìn lời trên lỗi như thế này.
Tôi cũng giám chắc có cơ quan liền đến tốt tổn đàn.
Không ai không chỉ lỗi,
bất cứ một ai trong quá trình tốt tổn như hoang xanh.
Bình không qua đồ hỗ trình như thế,